monsieur langlois bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
menée par le service départemental de la
police judiciaire des hauts-de-seine le
conducteur aurait agi délibérément avez
vous plus d'informations sur ses
motivations n'ont pour le moment pas de
l'information supplémentaire l'enquêté
en cours la stella précipitations
effectivement avec la nuit qui est
arrivé
nos collègues sont en train de déplorer
divers pistes et donc on n'a sûrement
pas plus que hier soir
alors on voudrait aussi avoir des
nouvelles de l'état de santé des deux
policiers percuté par ce chauffeur vous
en avez pas plus que ce que vous venez
d'annoncer le pareil le service
hospitalier fait son travail la minute
avec eux et puis maintenant bas nous
attendons des retours et les sons
reprendre des forces à nos collègues
alors est ce qu'il ya des pistes qui
sont à priviligier on parlait d'abord
peut-être une piste terroriste
hier est ce que c'est le cas toutes les
pistes sont toujours envisagées c'est
pas la piste prioritaire mais après
avoir laissé une lettre et avoir un
couteau il ya des possibilités que
maintenant c'est pas la piste qui est
privilégié sinon le parquet anti
terroriste serait déjà saisie de la
faire ce qui n'est pas le cas alors
c'est que alors on a appris également
que ce jeune homme de 29 ans
n'étaient pas fichés s il n'était pas
connu des services de police mais je
crois qu'ils avaient déjà été
interpellés il ya peut-être un an n'est
ce pas oui tout à fait d'aveux était
déjà été interpellé il n'est pas fiché
est ce effectivement après fichiers ça
veut pas dire qu'on est de toute façon
forcément susurre on est juste suspects
et qu'on affichait savait pas dire qu'on
a fait quelque chose
et puis être joué une première fois on
fait quelque chose déjà des gens qui
passent à l'acte sans avoir été fiché
sans être connu des services de police
ce précédemment donc c'est peu cette
personne a l'air d'être dans son cas ce
que la poêle est interpellé c'est
n'avait rien à voir avec ça et la chose
aussi qui pose le problème à l'heure
actuelle c'est aussi une recrudescence
des attaques de façon générale quand les
policiers nous avons eu un autre
collègue motard qui a été attaqué sur
une intervention de police ça a tremblé
hier également
donc en fait il ya aussi une volonté de
s'en prendre aux policiers à l'heure
actuelle cette volonté de s'en prendre
aux policiers vous venez de le dire est
ce que l a augmenté avec avec le
confinement c'est ce que vous constatez
si on constate on intervient sur tout le
territoire on est un des rares services
publics accord aller à droite à gauche
sur le territoire et dans les endroits
les plus difficiles
donc effectivement ça augmente et parce
que du coup les policiers sont déjà
n'ont pu les moyens d'avoir des renforts
comme c'était le possible avant on sait
qu'on est fragilisé par la crise du
court aux navires us open a qui en
profite malheureusement
merci beaucoup alexandre langlois
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat vigie cgt
police